Straight Ahead all lawn crime daily Alex
Jones is back in court unless you stop
it bully a bully will never stop himself
they've transformed their hearing
advantages they've transformed money
into a political weapon and strive and
we're going to ask you to disarm now
opening statements are presented in the
Infowars host's second defamation trial
plus the Pike County Massacre
testimony begins as George Wagner IV
faces the possibility of the death
penalty and the Man convicted in the
2018 beating death of baby Joe Clyde now
says he deserves a new trial and later I
know I have never seen so much alcohol
consumed by a pregnant woman a closer
look at the Parkland School Shooter's
childhood law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to Long crime daily I'm
your host Brian buckmeyer the second
trial in as many months Begins for a
conspiracy theorist and right-wing radio
host Alex Jones for his comments about
the Sandy Hook school shooting lawn
crime Network brought you the gavel to
gavel coverage of Jones's Texas trial
where a jury ordered him to pay 4.3
million dollars in damages to the
parents of Jesse Lewis a student who was
shot and killed in 2012. the Jones now
faces trial in Connecticut as 15
plaintiffs filed a total of three
lawsuits against him after he claimed
that the school shooting was a hoax put
on by crisis actors the plaintiffs made
up of family members of the students
killed and an FBI agent say Jones's
followers have harassed him and even
made death threats Jones has already
been found liable for the damages in
this case meaning jurors will now decide
how much Jones should pay the trial
expected to last for about four weeks as
a six-person jury hears evidence from
both sides on Tuesday opening statements
were presented the plaintiff attorney
showed jurors examples of Jones mocking
the Sandy Hook families
he says
but my heart does go out
to the people I see on the news who say
their parents
the problem is
I've seen soap operas before
and I know when I'm watching a movie and
I know when I'm watching something real
and he looks at the camera and he goes
let's look into seeing each other
and you're going to hear evidence that
that is a call to action
let's investigate it let's look into
these parents let's expose them to the
flaws that they are
keep scoring 2017. Sandy hooked vampires
exposed
now we're going to present you with
dozens of exhibits but the reality is of
videos and articles
nobody knows how many times they publish
this stuff
for Jones's defense attorney Norman
pattis argued the plaintiffs are using
money as a weapon in this case as a way
to stop Alex Jones
they've suggested your job is to punish
Alex Jones
they hate him because he says Thou
outrageous things and the haters want to
silence
each of you has chosen to be here today
to compensate them for their grief and
you're being asked to make an example of
Alex money is their Weapon of Choice
Award enough that you might summon it or
you might silence Alex Jones
he was mocked they're coming they're
coming they're coming
planish and their Council hope they're
here and it's you
that with money you'll do what no one
else you'll do what most of us do at
home when we hear something we don't
like it we turn on a few he said
joining us today is legal analyst Dr
Tracy Pearson and co-host Terry Austin
Dr Pearson similar to the last trial
this is just a question of how much
Jones pays not if he's liable so do you
expect a different result in this case
than the one in Texas
the short answer to your question Brian
is no I don't expect a different answer
to this to this issue uh we uh you saw
this morning that there was a
devastating uh decision made by the
judge at least devastating to Alex Jones
where the Court ruled that he could
introduce no evidence as a sanction no
evidence that he wasn't making money for
or making profit for uh the type of
lies that he was spreading because of it
his failure to comply with the Court's
orders regarding Discovery additionally
there are 15 plaintiffs here and that
means typically that where there are
more plaintiffs there's going to be
larger dollars yeah it's a bad news for
Jones as the last case was just one
plaintiff and it was 4.49 49.3 million
now could be a lot more Terry Jones's
team says an appeal is likely coming in
the Texas case and if he loses in
Connecticut I would assume the same here
so do you see any issues that he may win
on on appeal well you know he has the
right to appeal obviously and I assume
he is going to appeal both in Texas and
Connecticut but he's not going to be
able to claim ineffective counsel for
instance in Texas when defense counsel
accidentally sent those texts to
plaintiff's council he claimed that
because that can only be asserted in a
criminal case he also cannot claim that
he was not constitutionally given his
rights under the Sixth Amendment because
that doesn't apply in a civil case
either so he's going to have to argue
legal arguments evidentiary arguments
and essentially in both cases he's going
to have to say it was an error when the
judge did a motion and allowed the
plaintiffs to Prevail just based on the
fact that he defaulted on court orders I
don't think he's going to win under
those grounds I think that there is
sufficient evidence based on the
pleadings that the plaintiff did and I
think the verdict that was granted was
just absolutely we'll see how this case
continues as it progresses moving now to
Michigan where the trial is delayed for
the parents of Oxford High School
shooter Jennifer and James crumbly were
set to go to Trout next month on charges
of involuntary manslaughter the trial
has been delayed but no new date has
been set prosecutors say the couples
should have done more to prevent the
November 2021 shooting arguing they
exposed their son to a chaotic home life
and gave him access to the murder weapon
four students were killed and several
others injured when officials say a then
15-year-old gunman opened fire at Oxford
High School despite his age the
suspected shooter is being held in adult
jail as he awaits trial meanwhile
Jennifer and James crumbly argue their
charges should be dropped alleging they
could not have known what their son was
planning the couple is due back in court
on October 18th for a dobbert hearing
where the judge will review expert
witness testimony
still ahead on lawn crime daily Joseph
Daniels appeals his conviction and
fights for a new trial over the 2018
death of his son baby Joe but first
testimony begins in Pike County Ohio as
George Wagner IV stands trial on eight
counts of murder
welcome back Witnesses who found the
bodies of the eight members of the Rodin
and Gilly families took the stand in the
Pike County Massacre trial law and
crimes engine and Levy tells us what
they were told
Bobby Joe Manley is the younger sister
to Dana Rhoden and she called 9-1-1 that
morning back in April of 2016. in the
state of Ohio Witnesses and trials can
opt to not be recorded and Bobby Joe
Manley took that option
Bobby Joe Manley was frantic as she
called 9-1-1 but on this stand she was
stoic yet vulnerable she recalled
thinking something was off when she
arrived at Chris Rhoden senior's trailer
on April 22nd 2016. she said the inside
dogs were on the porch and the door was
locked her friend Billy Morgan got the
key from above the door frame and
unlocked the door once inside they saw
large drag marks of blood going back to
the bedroom that's where they found
Chris senior and Gary rhoden's bodies
under a comforter there's blood all over
the house
beat the hell out of
manly went next door to Frankie rhoden's
trailer to tell him his father was dead
Manley said she found Frankie Rhoden and
his fiancee Hannah Hazel Gilly in the
bed Hannah Hazel's breast was exposed
from breastfeeding and their
six-month-old son Ruger was on his hands
and knees in between his parents covered
in blood the rodents consult each other
as the jury looked at gruesome crime
scene photos Dana rhoden's brother James
Manley testified that he went into her
home and heard Hannah rhoden's newborn
daughter crying and found his sister
dead in her bed and when you got to
where you thought her head was what did
you do and I felt like a pillar over her
head
I started picking Bo up and you felt
stuck and I just at least I went out of
the house
so you started lifting up the pillow but
you could feel that it was sticking yeah
or it was stuck yeah okay
and you said then you
ran out of the house or when I just
turned around and walked back up Bobby
Joe Manley's friend Billy Morgan also
testified and didn't want to be on
camera he performed chores at Chris
rhoden's home for him and said sometimes
he smelled marijuana around an
outbuilding on the property Morgan also
said that there were surveillance
cameras mounted in several locations but
in the crime scene photos the
surveillance cameras are gone for Law
and crime daily I'm Anjanette Levy in
Waverly Ohio
thanks Anjanette Terry this case has a
lot of moving pieces and can be very
complicated at first glance could that
complication and somewhat chaotic
environment favor the defense in trying
to raise Reasonable Doubt no question
about it Brian the more complicated the
better for the defense the most
complicating part of this case is
keeping track of the names and the
relationships I mean we know already
that there are eight victims for
defendants four different crime scenes
and all of those individuals have people
who were involved in terms of finding
those individuals who were killed and so
the biggest issue for the prosecution is
going to keep everything straight you
want that jury to follow your story in
the case of the you know prosecution
trying to pursue the claims against
George it's going to be difficult to
establish that motive we know Jake had
the most because he was fighting for
custody but here the prosecution is
definitely going to have to establish
some forensic evidence they're going to
have to say look his DNA he bought the
gun he bought the ammunition they're
going to have to tie that circumstantial
evidence or some video into the crime
for him I think that might be a little
bit difficult they have evidence against
you know obviously Jake against Angela
but I think it might be difficult and
all you have to do as you know is have
one juror who doesn't have you know in
their mind who has Reasonable Doubt and
doesn't want to convict and there you
have it so we'll see what happens but I
think there could be some doubt in the
case against George here yeah I can see
it as well Dr Pearson I'd love to ask
you about the witness's testimony today
but so many have opted out of being
televised what are your thoughts on the
Public's limited viewing of this trial
well Anjanette Levy has been critical in
this case to our understanding of what's
happening because we can't see these
Witnesses we can't hear them uh most of
them and so she is really our eyes and
ears in the courtroom when it comes to
ensuring the Integrity of the courts and
the public faith in the courts it's
essential that the Press be able to
broadcast these proceedings and any
proceeding in a courtroom we've had a
lot of political unrest in this country
if you will where people have attacked
our our systems of justice and it's
essential for us to be able to see these
things with our own eyes absolutely and
I agree with that make sure you follow
Angela Levy's Twitter as well as law and
crime because that's the only place
you're going to get that gabble to
gobble coverage of this case coming up
on lawn crime daily a Florida jury could
soon decide whether the Parkland school
shooter is sentenced a life in prison or
the death penalty plus the Man convicted
of baby Joe Clydes murder says he
deserves a new trial could his motion be
granted
[Music]
welcome back Joseph Daniels a man found
guilty in the murder of his son Joy Joe
Clyde Daniels appeals his conviction as
he argues for a new trial it's been more
than a year since a jury returned a
guilty verdict against Joseph as he
faced a first degree murder charge in
the beating death of his five-year-old
son baby Joe Joe Clyde was initially
reported missing in April 2018 he was
presumed dead just days later and his
body has never been found Joseph
confessed to the beating a beating of
Joe and hiding his body Joe Clyde's
mother Crystal Daniels admitted to being
present when their son died she was set
to go to trial earlier this year but
instead pled no contest that child abuse
charges and will serve 15 years in jail
Joseph was sentenced to life in prison
last fall but his attorneys now argue
there was insufficient evidence they say
his confession was coerced and that the
jury never should have been allowed to
hear the video in which Joseph says
quote why thou kill my son also at issue
was the lack of DNA or any other
physical evidence to prove Joe Clyde was
dead after he disappeared the motion
will likely end up at the state court of
appeals if Daniel's request for a new
trial is denied
Terry the defense is arguing there was
insufficient evidence to convict where
do you think the prosecution best fought
that argument
well you know it's a good argument but
obviously the jury disagreed with that
they thought there was plenty of
evidence to convict and even though it
was circumstantial they know for a fact
because the mother actually said she was
present when all of this was happening
she admitted to it and so she actually
saw baby Joe die they're also trying to
claim that that confession was coerced
not likely Brian because basically it
was a normal confession he was given
Miranda rights it wasn't extremely
lengthy and the judge admitted parts of
that video because clearly they
established a foundation and they showed
that the evidence was really introduced
correctly so there is no legal grounds
there so I don't think that he's going
to be able to argue anything as far as
an appeal is concerned he's saying they
lacked DNA and physical evidence that's
probably the best evidence that they're
going to have against you know saying
that this was insufficient to so I
definitely think that you know the
appeal at the end of the day is not
going to Prevail yeah we'll see how it
continues Dr Peterson with what we've
heard so far where do you think the
Judge is leaning uphold the conviction
or reverse well you know I try not to
predict because things can go wonky very
easily but there is an unreasonably High
burden for a new trial in Tennessee you
have to show there's no material
evidence to support the verdict this
taking the strongest reasonable view of
the evidence in favor of the verdict
inferences must be drawn in favor of the
verdict and you have to dispose of any
contrary evidence so he's got a really
Steep Hill to climb and so I I while I'm
not predicting I think it's probably
unlikely he's going to get a new trial
and I feel like I got a tiny prediction
out of you they're a doctor but we'll
see how it continues I tend to agree
it's going to be a uphill battle for
Joseph Daniels in this case when we come
back we head to Florida for the Parkland
school shooter penalty phase trial what
Witnesses the defense calls on day 23 of
the trial
[Music]
welcome back to Lawton crime daily the
jury hears from a fetal alcohol syndrome
expert as testimony continues for the
11th day of the defense's case in the
Parkland shooter penalty phase trial on
February 14 2018 a then a 19 year old
gunman opened fire at Marjory Stoneman
Douglas High School in Parkland Florida
17 people were killed and 17 more
injured in October of last year the
government pled guilty to all charges
it's now up to a Broward County jury to
determine whether the defendant will
receive life in prison or the death
penalty for its case so far the defense
has narrowed in on the defendant's
troubled childhood pointing the finger
at both his biological and adoptive
mothers multiple Witnesses have
testified that the defendant's
biological mother knowingly used drugs
and alcohol while pregnant with him on
Tuesday a fetal alcohol syndrome expert
testified that he had never seen so much
alcohol consumed by a pregnant woman
Nick's mother
had really very poor prenatal care and
we know prenatal care is absolutely
critical for
um for a child at the second prenatal
visit which was at 28 weeks
um
her her weight the mother's weight had
decreased over that period of time so as
opposed to gaining weight during the
entire second trimester for pregnancy
she actually lost weight and the size of
the fetus based on a fun what they call
a fundal height had
not grown through that period of time as
well so the whole issue of prenatal care
I think is is critical in the fact that
she actually lost weight I think is
critical as well based on his health in
in utero so her nutritional status was
horrible and I suspect that it was and
this is obviously speculation on my part
but I think it's quite likely related to
the alcohol exposure that she had during
that part of her pregnancy
Dr Pearson if the jury was to decide
life in prison what evidence so far do
you think would be the reason for that
I think hearing from that expert gave
the jury the opportunity to grab onto
something scientific something real that
they could hold on to I also think that
hearing about his troubled childhood
where he found his father dead where he
struggled in school and the school
didn't implement the right kinds of
interventions we heard from another
expert who testified that the right
kinds of interventions were not
implemented for him to help him catch up
developmentally I also think that there
is a piece of evidence that may backfire
on the prosecution and that is the video
of Nicholas Cruz speaking into the
camera before the shooting where it
supports Melissa McNeil's contention his
defense lawyers contention that well his
brain was simply just broken
Terry as I hear the shooter's mitigation
I can see how it affected his acts but
could this evidence against him be
Beyond mitigation or is there a chance
for life in prison
well with human nature I think there is
a chance for life in prison again we
just need that one person and he would
get life in prison if that person can't
say we will vote for him to be put to
death we heard from multiple Witnesses
they're all confirming the same thing
that he was impacted by that fetal
alcohol syndrome we heard Dr Kenneth
Jones testified today that there was
more alcohol consumed by his birth
mother than anyone else he had ever seen
and we previously heard from Paul Connor
who was a neuropsychologist he said that
people with fetal alcohol syndrome
disorder they demonstrate everything
that the defendant demonstrated meaning
he had impulse control issues he had
difficulty socializing and then
essentially we heard from all of the
teachers who said that they saw exactly
that type of behavior that all of these
Physicians were saying the defendant
really demonstrated so I think there
could very well be one person on that
jury who is looking at this as if to say
you know look it's not his fault so
we'll see we'll see we see a lot of
people fetal alcohol syndrome but not a
lot of people do the shooting that he
did well thank you for joining us here
on lawn and crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss Justice in
America
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]